thank you guys so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
i'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of Nespresso am I the first
president of man I think you're the
first good morning believe nation
today's message is have role models over
to you Tim Howard TV go I have role
models in particular role model in
sports growing up Chris Jackson nothing
of the Rove and he played basketball NBA
and was just great to watch him you know
he was a nine-year-old kid you know so I
saw him doing amazing things on TV it
was like wow you can really achieve
something here and then I set my mind to
I just kind of tried to be as good as I
could it soccer and work hard and see
what I got in and through that process
because of TS obviously other people
were inspired by me the same when I was
like fish Jackson when someone comes up
to me and says well you know they feel
isolated in school and they feel kind of
like the outcasts and that I give them
that that kind of courage is pretty cool
so what do you think I think that was a
great video I think it's so important to
have role models as children and even as
adults as a child my role model where my
parents who inspired me both personally
and professionally and later on lawyers
that I worked with over time were also
personal and professional inspirations
so continue to have role models keep
finding them to find your inspiration
and your motivation I love it I think
you need people to push you outside your
comfort zone I think we're both
fortunate i had insane parents and
seeing the amazing parents not insane
parents insanely amazing parents who
taught me to believe in myself as for
belief comes from for me and part of why
I created the top 10 series in the
ancestor series to try to learn from
people who have done a lot more than us
it's like Tim Howard like if you hang
your own success hopefully some of it
rubs off onto you a little bit more I
would also say don't use like if you
don't have great
parents don't use that as a as a crutch
like oh I can't be successful because I
didn't have role models growing up I had
terrible parents so I don't renew my
parents right like take responsibility
for your life and go and find new role
models now use the videos like I think
you'll also have aspirational role
models where I learned from steve jobs
and walt disney and AP Giannini even
though i'm never going to meet them you
know they're dead but but their lessons
still help me and i consider them to be
my role models now so it's in it's an
insanely valuable thing to have role
models to not just try to figure
everything out all on your own but if
you don't have them yet don't let that
like keep you down go out take
responsibility and go find role models
for your life so the question they today
is what did you learn from your parents
good or bad ooh going deep and just
going to leave it in the comments below
and we will join the discussion thank
you guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and
we'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot a vinspresso what you
looking at Jason the guy last week all I
see Jason behind the cameras like it's
like Jason what does happen it's like Oh
some girl walk why some ikea okay let's
let's focus on the so what do you think
I don't know anything and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another I
thought you're doing it together
espresso give me go